retour en france avec l'inquiétude du
maire de l'île aux moines dans le golfe
du morbihan
en ce mois d'août près de 12000
visiteurs débarquent quotidiennement sur
l'île et cette surpopulation vous allez
le voir provoque la saturation des
structures d'accueil
le reportage d'eric piolet et patrick
soulabaille ça ne bouge de partout il
faut être vigilant
c'est ça c'est le stress pas on a
toujours peur de d'un gamin qui traverse
gilou c'est le tati collectif de deylaud
moine il en connaît tous les chemins
pour transporter ses clients
une conduite au millimètre sur des
routes très étroites où l'on croit sans
arrêt des touristes à pied ou en vélo en
cette période estivale circuler est un
vrai tour de force tellement ils sont
nombreux à visiter l'île
la mi août c'est un format là on peut
plus circuler démodé
d après midi nous avons vue d'arrêter
parce qu'on a fait en photos olé au
meilleur moment de la saison près de
12000 visiteurs de passage débarque sur
l'île
les vedettes du golf les amène par
groupes entiers de port-blanc vannes ou
port navalo les pontons sont trop petits
pour les accueillir
et cette foule donne des frayeurs à la
municipalité chargée de veiller à la
sécurité publique ils vont se promener
jusqu'à 4h 5h à ça car ils en ont touché
ma roue ils ont peur de rater leur
passage et ils descendent tous une heure
avant leur départ programmé les
s'agglutinent alors sur les cales que
vous voyez là et c'est un flot de
population qui nous inquiétait qui nous
qui nous interpelle parce que si
quelqu'un tombe à l'eau on est
responsable de ça pour gérer ce flux
quotidien le maire réglemente la
circulation le centre du bourg est
réservée aux piétons une partie de la
journée
cette concentration induit aussi des
nuisances avec les déchets qu'il faut
ramasser pour garder les plages propres
les trois cantonniers de lille aidé de
deux saisonniers s'avère insuffisant
avec un petit budget la commune fait
face difficilement sans trop se plaindre
car tu es touristes aident à maintenir
une activité
il n'y a pas de points qu'ils ont envie
s'il est des locations et finalement les
les garagistes avec la réparation enfin
bon et les artisans donc s'ils profitent
du tourisme le niveau de fréquentation
est telle que les infrastructures
d'accueil arrive à saturation en juillet
et août
trouver le bon équilibre et mieux
contrôler les passages la question
devient sur cannes et plus urgents